[Music]
in 1901
david hanig published a paper that
forever changed our
understanding of taste his research led
to what we know today
as the taste map an illustration that
divides the tongue
into four separate areas according to
this map
receptors at the tip of our tongues
capture sweetness
bitterness is detected at the tongue's
base and along the sides
receptors capture salty and sour
sensations
since its invention the taste map has
been published in textbooks and
newspapers
the only problem with this map is that
it's wrong
in fact it's not even an accurate
representation
of what hanig originally discovered the
tongue map
is a common misconception something
widely believed
but largely incorrect so where do
misconceptions like this come from
and what makes a fake fact so easy to
believe
it's true that the tongue map's journey
begins with david hennig
as part of his dissertation at leipzig
university
hennig analyzed taste sensitivities
across the tongue
for the four basic flavors using sucrose
for sweet
quinine sulfate for bitter hydrochloric
acid for sour
and salt for salty hennig applied these
stimuli to compare differences
in taste thresholds across a subject's
tongue
he hoped to better understand the
physiological mechanisms
that affected these four flavors and his
data suggested that sensitivity for each
taste did
in fact vary across the tongue the
maximum sensation for sweet was located
at the tongue's tip
bitter flavors were strongest at the
back salt was strongest in this area
and sour at the middle of the tongue's
sides but hennig was careful to note
that every sensation could also be
tasted across the tongue
and that the areas he identified offered
very small variations
in intensity like so many misconceptions
the tongue map represents a distortion
of its original source
however the nature of that distortion
can vary
some misconceptions are comprised of
disinformation
false information intentionally designed
to mislead people
but many misconceptions including the
tongue map
center on misinformation false or
misleading information
that results from unintentional
inaccuracy
misinformation is most often shaped by
mistakes
and human error but the specific
mistakes that lead to a misconception
can be surprisingly varied in the case
of the tongue map
hennig's dissertation was written in
german
meaning the paper could only be
understood by readers fluent in german
and well-versed in hennig's small corner
of academia
this kicked off a game of telephone that
reshaped hennig's research
every time it was shared with outside
parties
less than a decade after his
dissertation newspapers were falsely
insisting that experiments could prove
sweetness was
imperceptible on the back of the tongue
the second culprit behind the tongue
maps spread were the images that
hennig's work
inspired in 1912 a rough version of the
map
appeared in a newspaper article that
cautiously described some of the
mysteries
behind taste and smell research
featuring clear labels across the tongue
the article's illustration simplified
hennig's more complicated
original diagrams variations of this
approachable image
became repeatedly cited often without
credit
or nuanced consideration for hennig's
work
eventually this image spread to
textbooks and classrooms
as a purported truth of how we
experience taste
but perhaps the factor that most
contributed to this misconception
was its narrative simplicity in many
ways
the map complements our desire for clear
stories
about the world around us a quality not
always present in the sometimes messy
fields of
science for example even the number of
tastes we have
is more complicated than hennig's work
suggests
umami also known as savory is now
considered the fifth
basic taste and many still debate the
existence
of tastes like fatty alkaline metallic
and water-like once we hear a good story
it can be difficult to change how we see
that information
even in the face of new evidence so
next time you see a convenient chart or
read a surprising anecdote
try to maintain a healthy skepticism
because misconceptions can leave a
bitter taste
on every part of your tongue did you
know that 70
of statistics are made up including this
one how can we avoid being tricked by
statistics
when they're so persuasive and make
complex data
digestible check out this video about
simpson's paradox
and learn how to make sense of
statistics